police in Los Angeles are trying to
predict the future we know where crime
happened yesterday but where is it going
to happen tomorrow in the next day and
they're not alone
more and more departments are using
data-driven algorithms to forecast crime
it's all about improving accuracy and
improving our effectiveness or
efficiency in our service to the
community when you see more police
officers you see the lights hear the
sirens the high visibility of officers
does deter crime in certain areas
proponents say it's helping to reduce
crime but others wonder at what cost
I think it targets and it just justifies
in their eyes racial profiling I've just
really worried about the world that my
son is going to enter into become a
young man in and I don't want people to
look at him and prejudge him that could
be life or death if someone calls the
police on you the algorithm is always
going to augment the system that it's in
and if the system itself is biased is
unjust then the algorithm is gonna
replicate that predictive policing is
changing policing in your city now and
we need to start asking the hard
questions about has an impact civil
rights has an impact privacy has it
impact suspects has it impact officers
doing their job here's how we're gonna
work for tonight certain floors will be
out of 160 say you're living in Los
Angeles and you just got out of prison
the LAPD could be keeping tabs on you
through a program known as operation
laser it uses crime arrests and field
data to determine where violent crimes
are likely to take place and who will
perpetrate them laser predicts who will
commit a crime before a crime actually
happens
groups like the stop LAPD spying
coalition are sounding the alarm in
local communities they say predictive
policing strategies like laser
disproportionately target low-income
people and communities of color why do
you believe that this data is subjective
the data is subjective and the data is
biased because policing practices have
always impacted black and brown and poor
people now we have predictive policing
just coming in with a veneer of science
trying to tell us that that somehow
making policing more objective but what
we're finding is that it's only
augmenting the way that policing
operates the laser program tries to
predict who might commit by
crime using a point system for example
if you're on probation that's five
points on your record if you're in a
gang that's another five a stop by
police can get you another point the
people with the highest scores in each
of LA's 21 divisions are placed on a
list called the chronic offender
bulletin you tally up all those numbers
some folks end up with two points some
folks end up with 40 points those that
are that end up with the highest number
of points we'll take a look and see
where are they now the most troubling
thing about the chronic offender
bulletin it's recriminate been on parole
who have served their time it seems kind
of hard to avoid police contact when
that's your home and this is your
history and the contact is coming to you
well not necessarily
if you live in the area and you did time
and you've got a job and you're doing
everything you're supposed to be doing
then you're not gonna be getting that
constant police contact police say
they're just being proactive what we
don't want is for that person to
recommit another crime go back to jail
and keep on the cycle so we try to get
ahead of it the problem is the public
has no way of knowing who's being
targeted which is why the stop LAPD
spying coalition is suing the city for
more information police are supposed to
inform individuals if they're on the
list but we reached out to the ACLU
legal aid and several defense attorneys
and none of them knew of anyone who had
been contacted by LAPD we feel that the
people have the right to know what is
going on in this program they may not
know the name of laser and they may not
know it the specifics of how it operates
but I think they do know exactly what's
happening that they're being monitored
because people in the community they
speak about it they say you know the
officer came up to me and said I see you
I know your brother
I got your brother I'm gonna get you it
is one part social control hey we're
watching you and it's one part
information question we are seeing who
you're associating with the car you're
driving who you're hanging out with your
neighborhood and they're recording all
that and putting it back into a larger
ever-growing database that's used for
investigative purposes
and laser is just one of several new
smart policing strategies some
departments are also considering drone
surveillance and body cameras equipped
with facial recognition technology this
video from the maker of an AI powered
body cam demonstrates how the technology
could be used to find a missing child
not shown how they could use it to track
suspects meanwhile cities across the
country have embraced a predictive
policing approach that focuses not on
high-risk people but on high-risk places
putting entire neighborhoods under watch
critics worry it's targeting areas that
are already over policed the problem is
that if you're already over policing in
a certain neighborhood you're gonna be
predisposed to seeing data that's now
gonna tell you to keep putting more and
more officers in those areas Bari
Williams is an attorney who advises
startups in the bay area I absolutely
love technology I work in the sector but
I think that we need to be mindful of
how technology is created and how it's
used and how it can be used in the
various purposes one popular tool
focused on where crime will happen is
pred poll today more than 60 departments
nationwide use it to forecast crimes
like burglaries and car break-ins
everybody has a pretty good policing
already in the LAPD's Foothill division
one of the first to use pred pol it
starts with the daily roll call
officers get a map labelled with 10 to
20 hotspots they're encouraged to visit
during their shifts the more time they
spend in those areas the more likely
they are to deter crime or so the
thinking goes good work this is today's
predictive policing boxes we're going to
cover the three boxes that are in my
area in the north end of pacoima pred
pool forecast crimes based on patterns
from the last several years it analyzes
three elements of crime data the crime
type the location and the time it then
runs them through an algorithm and spits
out 500 by 500 foot hotspots or boxes
that officers should keep an eye on
right now we're experiencing a lot of
property crime that's what our
predictive policing boxes are going to
focus on officer Steve Nunez has worked
in the Foothill division for 16 years
what are you looking for as we cruise
around um you know looking for anything
suspicious
even even sometimes looking for cars
that that look like they've been sitting
here for a while anyone that is maybe
trying to open car doors just anything
that just doesn't fit at first we were
I don't know if we're gonna follow this
predictive policing and having a
computer tell us where to go but he's
become a believer in print bull crime
has gone down dramatically so part of it
I believe is predictive policing part of
it's just the community engagement has
to do with just officers going out there
and being proactive don't believe you
don't appear for like a month and all
that stuff like that so like I said I
won't impound it you know because I know
it is so I'll let you guys deal with it
but at least get it off the streets the
fundamental question here is can we
trust the data and algorithms that
police are using to predict crimes
algorithms and big data model simply
take inputs crunch them up to create
outputs so if your inputs are biased
your outputs are gonna be biased you
don't need to look far to find troubling
examples of algorithmic bias in 2016
Microsoft introduced an AI chat bot
called Tay which quickly started
repeating racist and anti-semitic
comments it picked up on Twitter then
there were those problematic google
autocompletes which are based on popular
human searches in January a Google
search for Islamists are turned up
results like Islamist SART evil and
Hitler is turned up Hitler is my hero
and there was also at the time the
Google Images algorithm mistook black
people for gorillas so what happens if
prejudiced data makes its way into
police work it's a seven for Barry
Williams that risk is personal the
biggest fear I have with predictive
policing and my son is that he will be
profiled I'm sure he probably will
experience that at some point in his
life already but I don't need something
making that easier did you have a good
day
Williams lives in Oakland the city that
so far has decided not to use pred poll
still she says the image of black
children being fatally mislabeled as a
threat by police looms large in her mind
in the case of Tamir rice you have a
child who was playing with a BB gun and
the police just rolled up and within
three seconds shot him and that is a
real concern for me my son and I like to
go certain places and if the
neighborhoods are not awesome and
predictive policing is telling you to
send more police into that area and
we're there I'm not gonna I'm not gonna
allow my child to go play in the street
I'm not gonna allow my child to run in
front
of me I don't want anything to give
police a false a false sense that he
could have been engaged in something he
wasn't the activists and the police are
all coming from the point that makes
sense for them I think from a community
perspective that feels over police that
feels that there is racial injustice and
policing it's wise to be concerned about
this new technology that's going to give
police more power if you're a police
officer you understand you have an
incredibly difficult job and adding new
technologies might help and you kind of
want to get the benefit the doubt
we've had crime rises over the last few
years we have car reduction
it is a tool it's not a panacea for
crime and that's what a lot of people
believe they believe that you utilize
pred pull crimes gonna go away false
that is a farce that is not gonna happen
so it's an indicator it takes you there
it could happen it could not it's a
probability the question about whether
predictive policing works is still open
one study found that proposed algorithms
correctly predicted crime just 4.7
percent of the time still that's higher
than the human analysts who got it right
just 2.1 percent of the time it's worth
noting that the study was done by the
company's co-founder and then there's
the question of bias you start coming
into the pakora area which is south of
the 210 freeway now you're dealing with
predominantly Hispanic families a lot of
immigrants in that area and I noticed
there are more boxes there the day we
visited most of the pred PO boxes in the
foothill division were in Hispanic
neighborhoods but police say that's by
chance I do believe the data is
objective we're simply using the crime
numbers the type of crime the location
and at the time of one we thought that
crime when that crime was reported to us
it has nothing to do with anybody's
ethnic makeup or or the neighborhood or
or anything else according to research
by pred Paul's co-founder their
algorithms don't lead to more arrests of
minorities than human policing but that
isn't exactly comforting to critics of
traditional policing the issue was that
crime tends to happen in all areas but
the problem is that marginalized groups
are where police are usually
congregating
and there is evidence of that disparity
today black and Hispanic Americans
account for about a quarter of the total
population but make up more than half of
the prison population and there may not
be a more infamous symbol of unjust
policing than the Rodney King beating
which happened right here in LAPD's
Foothill division 27 years ago that
beating and the riots sparked by the
acquittal of the officers involved
ignited a national conversation around
police brutality that continues today
members of the LAPD say that predictive
policing is helping them move forward as
an organization instead of being an
occupying force like we were referred to
once upon a time where there was a
problem in the area and we'd had to come
in with tons of cops we're trying to be
more strategic but activists like the
members of the Youth Justice Coalition
say that new technologies will only make
things worse
it's basically allowing them to racially
profile black and brown youth live Nona
in a low-income neighborhood mostly
black and brown people that live there
and there's always police on my block
but pretty boy I think it's doing is
targeting communities that they're
already been targeting stop LAPD spying
coalition is still pursuing their
lawsuit against the LAPD and for now the
most concerned citizens can hope for is
more transparency if there's a dialogue
between these police departments and the
communities that they're serving
explaining to them how they're using
these data points how they're using this
technology it may go a long way
predictive policing is here to stay and
so what we should do is figure out how
to identify the risks see them coming
and address them before her before it's
too late